now onto part 2 people end the review
how the Mandalorians are left
it seems like after episode 3 let's go
back oh no did you know about this it's
just a work of your bounty hunters no we
revealed ourselves I knew what could
happen come with us no I will not
abandon this place until I have salvaged
what remains and turned it into the most
awesome piece of armor you've ever seen
species can move objects with his mind I
know such things the songs of eons pass
tell them battles between Mandalore the
Great and an order of sorceress called
Jedi that Creed it is in your care you
get a man over to train this thing it's
too weak it would die you have no choice
you must reunite it with its own kind
wear this you must determine until it is
of age or reunited with its own kind
dad DeLorean it's official this is the
way you have earned your Signet
shazbot thank you I wear this with all
her all of this was worth it to get this
will make you complete until you know it
it will not listen to vacuum I
understand
[Laughter]
come with us
my place is here oh let's watch her I
kick some ass Wow now melt them there
you go ah God you can feel those hits Oh
Oh God this is the lava roller this is
the way oh yeah physics destroy the boat
oh whoa oh whoa dang suppose anybody
here speaks droid what sound is out on
this episode man yeah so great no
stormtroopers they're flanking the mouth
of the tunnel the greatest erotic an
entire platoon they must know we're
coming I'm the Troy was meant to bring
oh whoa the enemy and you will escape
you don't have that kind of firepower
mal compromised mass self-destruct are
you talking about I'm not permitted to
be captured man must be destroyed
are we gonna keep talking or we gonna
get out of here I can no longer carry
this for you you can't self-destruct
your base command is to watch the child
that supersedes your manufacturers
protocol right right this is correct
good now grab a blaster and help us
shoot our way out victory in combat is
impossible we will be captured the child
will be lost
Jesus sadly there's no scenario where
the child is saved in which I survive
come on man but you'll be destroyed and
you will live and I would have served my
purpose no we need you there's nothing
to be sad about I've never been alive
sad yes destroyed
[Music]
no t800 a nerd just not fixing him now
they've come a long way you gonna fly a
jet pack right hell yeah baby yes
snap oh
goddamn it no come on dude Oh a packet
you yes
no no no no no this thing here well why
not Star Wars you should still go check
to make sure he's dead yeah well done
we've accomplished in it'll take care of
you
[Music]
whoa what do you got there
why don't you hang on to that your yo
DeLorean now
and so mando and the child went off off
get he's gonna be getting out stretching
his legs Oh still alive
[Music]
it's not Darksaber is it
Oh looks like an artery BRR
oh my Sith Lord
Wow
now that should be in the thumb it is
tango I think episode it hit me because
I was like the comedy oh ok yeah at the
top yeah alright got some thoughts about
the mando episode 8 series finale but
before we go into that like I said
full-length reaction stream belongs are
at our patreon page and over there were
two weekly Q&A s and stream belongs for
other shows like agents of shield Gotham
stranger things season 3 and other ones
as well and then there's shows where we
have stream alongs and the option of
reaction highlights included like what
you saw here for the Mandalorian and
those shows are supernatural Hunter
hunter turd Geass Death Note
my hero academia movie included and
other shows as well
so guys gonna wrap patreon page to check
out all that stuff anyway let's talk
about this show well Jon did it stick
the landing for you yeah I think so it
didn't necessarily end with like a
massive flaw but it really stayed
consistent throughout the whole season
set up things for next time and it was a
couple pretty big like Star Wars Easter
egg surprises so I'm a satisfied
customer should we Google first to see
if people hate or love this so we know
how to lead our review yes we shouldn't
ever just have our own opinions we
should always meter them through the
opinions of the majority okay just give
us one I really did like this episode a
lot it might not be my favorite one of
the season but I think in terms of
arcing and wrapping up a season one and
successfully setting up a season two
given I was planning to look forward to
right off the bat I was like a little
bit taken aback by I mean when you learn
it's taiko YTD who directed it I wonder
if that might have shifted my perception
a little bit more if I knew my Cove was
directing this episode but I'm actually
glad I didn't come to think of it
because I think I would have been
looking at and expecting a lot more
humor throughout then if that were the
case the same time seeing that opening
scene which I don't know how people
generally are responding to that I have
no idea people actually think of this
episode I thought it was a funny scene
it might have gone on a little too long
for my taste but for the most part I
thought it was really funny and it's
kind of refreshing and I love the little
digs
one thing over there this March ever
just can't you no matter what obi-wan
says they suck at aiming the whole time
every time they were hitting baby Yoda
it was like stop eating it stop hitting
him please yeah nice to get a little
sensibility shift and watch people be so
indelicate about it yes after so much
time being so delicate about it it
seemed like this episode was really i g
xi and mandos episode or what was his
name Dijon mustard yeah fables that are
around
yeah seemed like it was both their
episodes like in terms of the redemption
theme that seemed to kind of fit a
little bit more towards IG xi in some
ways I like some of the subversion that
they did an example like when they go
down to the tunnels and all the mando
masks are just there
it's crazy what this show can do with
making it feel more violent by the
effect of costumes and armor like when
the oh no the tol you yeah well like
when the armor is jacking up all those
stormtroopers or even the shootout
fights feels like more violent than
what's actually happening on screen
because you can imagine the gore
underneath the costumes and stuff or the
little nugget when mando you check
behind his head and there's some blood
there to show like no these guys are
probably bleeding underneath all this
you know oh yeah if there's one thing
that modern storytellers have gotten
great at it's making violence seem
violent in a pg-13 scenario so that it
hits but there's there's nothing except
for maybe a little blood on someone's
hand if it's a main character which I
mean you know is used to great effect
here and it makes a lot of sense because
of things like Thor I'm like the anti go
I do seems like a perfect choice to
directed a show like this you know that
has sort of an imagination and it has a
certain humor of the world because you
have so many cultures clashing all the
time that scene at the beginning was a
nice subversion to me of just tone
because the last thing I was expecting
was like a chilling out and bantering
with these two cameras you know the use
of IG 11 I thought they might have
gotten doubled down knowing Tycho YTD
was voicing the droid they would have
done a little bit more comedy but it
seemed in tune with the character like
when IG 11 has decided he's going to
sacrifice himself in order to save that
I thought that was a nice moment people
like us are obviously gonna flash the
Terminator with a droid sacrificed
himself according to a pit of lava you
know even that little nugget of man
dough because it was like he sounds
really sad that IG 11 is dying right now
yeah which took me you a little bit by
surprises I'm like oh he's suddenly
grown really attached to him which does
make sense considering the IG eleven
ultimately did save his life but I like
that redemptive arc between them like
how this comes full circle with them the
first episode had both of them who were
completely different types of people or
you know personalities and characters at
the first episode and then by the time
you get to hear the last episode really
tying and making a full circle I thought
was brilliant a lot of people you know
we're thinking that this is pretty much
only episodic this episode really
showcases know this whole thing is very
much see realized even in ways that are
more subtle than we might have realized
it would be you know I like that little
arc for mando because you get to have a
g11 prove basically everything he's been
doubting about him up until this point
so that by the time you reach the
episodes end you're like oh yeah like
you do want him to be part of the team
and that's a good note for us because we
also ostensibly are endear to release I
was endeared to IG 11 so yeah that
sacrifice carries some weight and I also
appreciated that little detail of the
comedy like they actually called some
self-aware attention to the fact that he
tries to make a joke when he's saving
mandos life in that one little moment
and that was cool you know - that whole
reminder that I am NOT a living thing so
technically there's a loophole under
which I can save yes that yeah they
utilize that character in a really nice
way across this and they didn't make him
some kind of get-out-of-jail-free card
which I also appreciate it's finite I
can do this one thing and that was to a
nice flip on what I'm used to from a lot
of these kinds of shows because it seems
like when you get right down to it all
it takes is somebody's will going no we
can find out another way and they do and
this time it was nice to have the droid
be like look I've run every possible
scenario and the only way we can get
this done is is this means well that
seed was planted since episode 1 when
he's trying to self-destruct in the
middle of the battle yeah yeah yeah and
that was pretty a nice reward for that -
a nice little like through line
connector I feel like more people have
been learning lately like we didn't
realize it's a later
or get confirmed information about it
that it's not Pedro Pascal underneath
the mando Armour at least for most of
this I wasn't expecting to see his face
I still thought they even if he does
take off the mask I thought we were just
gonna shoot around it hide it still so
we didn't see it in some way I probably
might have preferred that but I'm also
not bothered by the fact that we did see
his face and even though we know Pedro
Pascal was cast in it it was still cool
to see him here and there and then also
for the imagination purposes as the show
continues to solidify the image that
Pedro Pascal is underneath the armor
even though people who look into it will
find out that he's really not for a lot
most of the show it's easier to imagine
that it is Pedro Pascal perhaps to
Giancarlo Esposito on the other side of
this episode it's easy because we have
gusts in our minds you know at least if
you've seen Breaking Bad so he's good at
already at doing that very calm
terrifying presence but I like that you
know you have all the student
stormtroopers you have a firefight there
but his presence is so assured and so
calm and then capped off at the very end
with the dark saber bit like it seems
like he has the potential to be a pretty
nasty villain moving forward into the
next season especially because he's
supposed to be dead ostensibly he
already has this terrible reputation
yeah inquisitors well we watched that a
Mandalorian documentary and they did
talk about the dark saber being like a
ceremonial weapon for the Mandalore's or
like the leader or something yeah the
original Mandalore yeah so that's gotta
be a good punch to it when commando
finds out about that and like whatever
history that's linked into makes me
really curious about how much more of
this lower they're going to be taking
from the extended parts of the universe
because you know obviously it's
everyone's knowledge there's no name yet
or backstory for the Yoda species and
also you know on top of that we also
have this history coming in the armor
mentions the Jedi you know these like
wizards if I remember that documentary
correctly was forged you know like by a
Mandalorian Jedi so there's also that
cross that at least is opening itself up
to potential because baby Yoda has you
know obviously force power and whatnot
so it seems like there's a lot of things
that can mix together in the next season
there are gonna be interesting because
it seems like the Jedi and the
Mandalorians would be at odds but they
have this crucial link in the history
that's true and I think
Giancarlo Esposito kills it in this role
because he brings some of that poetic
nature that Werner Herzog had because I
didn't want that element to go away
considering the fact that they killed
him off but he also brings that Menace
of a general feel like the Star Wars
movies are always trying to convey but
doesn't quite get there because they're
usually underneath you know Vader or
kylo Ren or something and he has that
I'm like man this character would have
been great to it in one of the movies as
a true evil general part of the Empire
he's also such a personal villain that
they set up an a more personal than I
anticipated like when he's like talking
to them at the beginning listening off
their entire background I'll find out
what Cara that she's from I mean there
might have been another episode your
founder she's from Alderaan
but I guess information in stick with me
or we just learned it now I feel crystal
Slayer cameo huh she's Lili a sister
something oh my god there's a third
Skywalker we didn't know about that
element but even he knew who mando was
not just that there was a Mandalorian
but his exact identity nando remember
who he was and how that linked and I
thought that was a nice structure with
its storytelling of having that reveal
and then truly getting the full
flashback because we've only seen hints
of it he's talked about it we knew what
occurs in the flashback but it also does
set up why he really fell in love with
the Mandalorian creed in that hammer on
the nail even harder why he has chosen
to take care of baby Yoda in this
episode you know which in turn makes it
more heartbreaking when you do discover
all those mandos or I've been killed I
do have one criticism though because I
love the action in this episode the
shootout especially at the tavern I
thought really seemed like a video game
with him like taking off the Gatling gun
mmm oh you know round with it Brian
maybe halo and then even with moth
Gideon being wise enough to actually
shoot mando then shoot in the tank right
next to him like that just seemed like
cool video game like shooter action to
me but even when he got like the jetpack
that on top of the TIE fighter that moth
Gideon was going down the set pieces
were cool you know armor taking out all
those stormtroopers was neat I did have
an issue the tone shift was too much the
TIE fighter went down Mothe Gideon in it
they're just like let's the end of the
episode who will wrap it up in yeah I
was like you guys should check
if he's dead the second it didn't
explode I was like yeah that's that's an
issue and just the way that the shift in
the way that the tone of that scene was
handled I can't tell if they were trying
to go for some type of self-aware thing
like oh though we want the audience to
kind of be aware that something's not
complete here or whatever for me
personally it didn't flow into that next
thing okay that welcoming they would
want to check on yeah it was like cool
to see the dark saber moment but I was
also a little bit annoyed by the fact of
being here in the audience perspective
going you guys would have checked
I've seen you characters enough to know
you would have checked to make sure he
was especially our main character would
have checked to make sure he was dead
considering he knows who he is instead
of just being like well that's done
victory complete you know what I mean
there's no I just didn't buy that
especially for a character who's already
supposed to have died once yeah and it
was too much of a moment of them just
celebrating and like let's move on and
let it Nino setup what we could possibly
be in season two yeah and with baby Yoda
I mean he got some like cool moments in
here like that moment with the with the
fire obviously was you know a big
highlight moment in every image every
time there's a frame of him you're like
yeah I love it at the same time though
they probably could have done something
that was not as predictable you know is
more special yeah because there's more
of what we've seen baby Yoda pretty much
doing they've been doing a good job at
like building up some stuff like when he
first lifts up that Rhino or whatever
and then the second episode the force
choke the life force healing abilities I
didn't want him to be a scapegoat cuz it
seemed like a lot was already going to
IG 11 for being the savior in so many
situations so it probably would have
lessened the stakes to some degree if
baby Yoda was also like going full baby
Yoda in this episode I thought that was
part of the point too is they addressed
that they're like hey do the thing do
the hand thing yeah I can't yeah that's
true but it's also us sprinkling these
little seeds with the species of Yoda of
mandos gonna be on an adventure looking
for the species or baby or am I just a
Mandalorian itself which would be pretty
cool I think that would be really neat
and I think in terms of wrapping up you
know some Star Wars lore and wondering
why we haven't seen other Yoda species
or whatever the
questions that have come up from
introducing this child character I feel
like having baby Yoda grow up to be
Amanda Lord was always wearing a mask
probably better at concealing that you
know I just can't help but wonder what
that's gonna look like cuz he's just
gonna be this little tiny guy with this
huge mask
well now even when Yoda is not gonna
grow up to be six feet tall he's gonna
be like three feet tall forever that's
true he's gonna like if Yoda Yoda was
nine hundred years old and he only got
to be yay high it's gonna look a little
funny in that armor and making fun of
little people no I'm just saying you
know like Yoda is smaller than a little
person bye-bye all like you can make you
know it's like they have child's size
Mandalorian armor but like Yoda is just
like a head and like this little what if
it was the mask and the ears were
popping out that would be great I would
love that
or maybe they'll get him armored your
plates best car steel ear guards man
maybe they'll double down and we'll just
see a whole species of baby Yoda's
season three is gonna just be all Yoda
characters and only pet my real only
quor'toth other than some you know at
times like with the stormtroopers I
never really feel the tension with them
because of stormtroopers and the show
even goes out of its way to poke at it
super suck at shooting even when they're
in the tunnel and they're like there's
too many of them we can't take them out
part of my brain sitting here he goes
really you sure about that yes might be
able to even if they're waiting for you
at the end of the tunnel I feel like
they might be you might be able to still
handle them there's stormtroopers some
lack of tension there and then of course
that one moment that I really hone in on
at the same time though I would have
been let down if Moff Gideon just cuz
there's like always this bill them to
this character this whole thing we're
trying to obtain the child we still
don't know why they want the child it
would have sucked if they just killed
him off it's neat to set up your
ultimate baddie for season two like this
by just utilizing your last two episodes
I think that's about the only thing that
this show could I think could benefit
from in terms of you know the only thing
I think the episode is missed by not
being feature-length is a little bit of
that tension that comes with the action
you know your league characters you're
not afraid are gonna die or get clipped
or anything like that so there is a
certain element of maybe drawing things
out in a certain way could increase that
tension but that's a minor criticism
just because it's not
really the point yes isn't the action
the action is just a cool trapping of
the world we get to inhabit you know
it's like yeah I have that emotional
sense of I would like some more suspense
for certain sequences that like that
level of true intensity for mote more of
the show to occur but I'm always engaged
I'm always fascinated about what's
happening and I love the team that he's
I mean even when it's different people
just like him working together with
whoever he's got is always a good you
know recipe for some interesting scenes
alright guys well the mandalorian what
you guys think of the season overall did
you think the season 1 finale hit the
mark comment below you guys and
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bill check us out on
patreon and have yourself a happy new
year